hi folks and welcome to the session on
advanced I am where we'll be covering
tips and tricks around
I am policy management I'm Blake a
product manager here at Google where I
primarily focus on the cloud Identity
and Access Management product which
serves as a central point for access
policy management and authorization
enforcement across the Google cloud
platform we're here today to dive a bit
deeper than usual into how you manage
your access policies particularly
through the API has both best practices
in this area we're going to be taking a
look at the policies themselves where
they can be configured across your cloud
infrastructure how based on your
policies Google determines when to grant
access to a user different versions of
the policies schema that are available
and finally how you can manage your
policies more safely by following some
simple best practices let's look at how
I am policies that appear themselves
when you're managing them through the
g-cloud command line or directly through
the API amongst some other aspects that
we'll get into in a bit they're
primarily made up of bindings in this
example you can see the first binding
grants the storage admin role to an
individual user Alice as well as to a
group called admins there's a second
binding in this policy that grants Bob
the compute admin role roles of course
are groups of granular permissions in
GCP the storage admin role would let you
create buckets and retrieve or store
objects in those buckets the compute
admin role would contain the permissions
to do things like create VM instances so
you may have noticed that the policies
only talked about who can do what they
didn't indicate the where in effect in
what areas of your cloud infrastructure
they can perform these actions
that's where policy attachment comes in
your cloud infrastructure in GCP is
organized in the resource hierarchy all
of it exists under the organization node
which typically represents the company
you work for under this you can create
folders for further categorization such
as business units regions or environment
types ultimately though your cloud
resources themselves such as the storage
buckets VMs or database instances will
end up being created and managed in
projects now I am policies can be
attached to any of these nodes
haier they're placed in the hierarchy
the more they grant access to this is
because the effects of policies inherit
down because projects usually end up
being a logical grouping of resources
that represent a particular workload
they're a frequent attachment point for
i.m policies to keep the effect of those
policies scoped to just that workload
however for many resource types it is
possible to set the policy even lower
you could for example grant a user
access just to a single VM in a project
rather than all of them so let's take a
look at how you can set policies at
different levels in GCP the policies are
retrieved or modified through ap eyes
that are made available by the service
related to where you want to set the
policy for example setting policies and
projects folders or the organization
node is all done through the resource
manager service or setting a policy on a
particular pub/sub topic would be done
through the pub sub service the method
to modify iam policies is called set iam
policy here you can see it exposed on
the resource manager endpoint for
projects or the pub sub endpoint related
to topics but how can you find which
resource types support iam policy
attachment and which API is to call for
each one good place to start is the API
reference documentation start by looking
up the reference for the service related
to where you want to set a policy next
find the resource type upon which you
wish to set that policy and lastly look
for the set iam policy method note to
where this exists there will also be a
get iam policy method which is what you
can use to retrieve any existing policy
attached to that resource all of this
documentation is available on cloud
google.com slash Docs but what if you
want to get a bit fancier Google
provides an API discovery service which
itself is an API you can use to pull
information about api's that Google
makes available including the methods
they provide let's take a look at the
list API is call as you've probably
expected from its name it returns a list
of Google API as you can use in the
example here we're looking
at the compute API entry that was
returned from this call this of course
refers to the Google Cloud compute
engine API in its listing it also
includes the discovery rest URL for the
service
let's query that in reviewing the
discovery document for a specific API
you can see all resource types it
exposes and the methods supported on
each of those resource types so for
example we can see here that there is a
set I am policy method available for OS
images meaning that you can set
different iam policies on different OS
images if you wish for you to set the
right policies it's helpful to
understand how Google evaluates them
when making access decisions referring
back to our resource hierarchy let's say
Alice wants to delete a particular
bucket called bucket a inside of this
project this is the iam policy set on
that project in it we can see a binding
that grants Alice the storage admin role
so the I am what are our inputs here to
evaluate we effectively need to
determine if a certain principle alice
has the storage buckets delete
permission to be used against bucket a
to do so we need to grab any potentially
relevant iam policies in hierarchy this
includes grabbing the policy on the
bucket itself the project is in the
folder that project is under and the
policy on the organization node itself
so we have our query and we have all the
relevant policies here evaluation
ultimately happens binding by binding
the default state is not to grant access
unless a policy explicitly says to
starting at the bucket we can see its
policy contains no bindings so this
policy does not grant access in moving
up to the project however we see our
binding from before that grants Alice
the storage admin role because alice is
indicated in the policy and the storage
admin role contains the storage buckets
delete permission this binding would
grant access in continuing however we
encounter another binding Alice is not
listed in this binding nor does the
compute admin role can
the needed permission at the folder
level we see that group foo is granted
the owner role but because Alice is not
in that group this binding also does not
grant her access this is similar when
looking at the policy on the
organization node Alice is neither a
member of the admins group nor is she a
member of the security group all that
said the evaluation decision tier is to
allow her to delete the bucket this is
because all I am bindings are additive
if any grant access the action will be
allowed especially when you have a large
amount of infrastructure deployed to
Google Cloud it can sometimes be
difficult to determine whether a user
does or does not have access to perform
a given action on a specific resource to
help you better understand and visualize
the evaluation logic we just went
through Google provides a tool in the
cloud console web UI called the policy
troubleshooter in it you can enter
exactly the same three pieces of input
we just talked about the principle the
permission and the resource policy
troubleshooter will then show you the
effective access decision as well as all
the bindings and their effects in each
relevant iam policy this can help you
make adjustments to policies if the
resulting access decision is not what
you intended to recap where you attach
policies matters you can simplify policy
management by setting them further up in
the hierarchy to grant more access but
also lower down on the project or on
individual resources when access needs
to be more fine-grained all bindings are
additive so it's important to understand
the bindings you've configured to ensure
you're not granting access to someone
you did not intend understanding the
permissions in the roles you're granting
and who are members of the groups to
whom you've granted access as well as of
course who controls the membership in
those groups are both important aspects
of making informed policy management
decisions and finally you can use tools
that Google provides to better
understand the effect of state of your
policies one more thing before we move
on just because sometimes this trips
people up for some types of permissions
they're checked relative to the parent
node compared to where you might think
that they would be let's take the
example of Alice trying to
create a bucket here we see she's
exercising the storage buckets create
permission but the resource upon which
this check is being performed is the
project in which she's trying to create
the bucket these parent checks occur on
permissions related to creating new
resources as well as listing resources
within a certain node so particularly
for list permissions make sure you're
granted these on the parent container if
you wish for a user to be able to
enumerate all resources of a certain
type within that container moving on I
am has added some new features since it
first launched recently one such feature
required us to version the schema of the
policy content itself let's take a look
at a basic policy example in February of
this year though we introduced a feature
called iam conditions which allows you
to configure when bindings should apply
or not here you can see a condition was
added to the binding that states its
effect is only valid for requests made
before January 1st of 2021 but you might
have also noticed the presence of this
condition bumped the version field in
the policy from 1 to 3 when I am
originally launched there were two
assumptions baked into policy schema one
was that each binding included one role
and a list of members and in any given
policy there would only be one binding
for a given role conditions
fundamentally changed this assumption
now you could have two bindings for the
same role granted to different people
under different conditions this has an
effect on how you retrieve policies as
well as how you modify them when
retrieving a policy using get iam policy
you can specify which schema version
you're requesting if you request version
3 it will return the policy with the
conditions objects included if however
you specify Jan 1 or do not specify a
version you will not receive all the
details of the conditions similarly for
set I am policy if you're submitting a
policy that includes conditions objects
you must set its version field 3 taking
a look here if you ran get I am policy
with the requested policy version set to
3 you'll see the same return we saw
earlier with the condition object and
however a schema version one is
requested for a policy that contains
conditions you'll only see an indicator
that there is a condition on a binding
via hash concatenated with the granted
roll name in reality though this is
pretty simple for existing and future
programmatic integrations that need to
read or write
I am policies just ensure they
understand the syntax and semantics
associated with the version 3 schema
namely this means your code should
understand that there can be multiple
instances of the same roll across
findings in a given policy and that some
of those bindings may include a
condition so as long as this is the case
you can always request version 3 on get
I am policy and set version 3 on set I
am policy finally today let's talk about
best practices when it comes to safely
modifying iam policies critically here
is understanding the get modified set
flow to modify any iam policy you must
first retrieve the current state of the
policy this is done by executing a get
iam policy call against the resource to
which the policy is attached once
retrieved your code can modify the
policy in any way necessary for example
you may wish to add an additional
binding to the policy in this case
giving Bob the compute admin role once
you were your code made the desired
changes the entire policy is submitted
back using the set I and policy call in
this example that includes any bindings
that were already there along with the
additional binding that you've added a
common mistake many people make early on
in using iam is only submitting their
changes in set I am policy rather than
the entire desired state of the policy
inclusive of their changes and any local
modification performed by you or your
code should follow the rules associated
with a policy schema version being
requested or set another best practice
is ensuring appropriate to currency
control is in place for your policy
modifications let's take a look at an
example where Alice and Bob are both
trying to modify a policy at roughly the
same time first Alice executes get I am
policy is the start of
get modified set sequence she or her
code then began making any desired
modifications to the policy locally Bob
then kicks off his get modified set flow
by requesting the policy currently set
and begins his local modifications here
is code then complete their changes and
successfully set the updated policy
shortly after however Alice's local
modifications are complete and her
updated policy is set this of course is
a very unexpected outcome because the
basis on which Alice's local
modifications were performed was the
result of a get I am policy issued
before Bob set I am policy Bob's changes
were effectively overwritten by Alice's
Sepahan policy to prevent situations
like this where two people may
accidentally step on each other's as
changes I am supports etags to provide
concurrency control when retrieving an I
am policy it will include an e-tag field
it represents the state of the policy as
it exists at that time during your
modification be sure to preserve this
key tag field exactly as it was returned
from get I am policy then ensure the
same a tag is included in the payload
during your set a.m. policy if the
policy on that resource is changed since
you last retrieved it you're set i am
policy call will appropriately fail so
to recap again always preserve you tag
field all the way through the get
modified set flow if the policy on a
resource has changed your set i on
policy call will fail with an HTTP 409
conflict response and in this case your
client can simply retry the entire get
modified set operation so as to
incorporate whatever the latest state of
the policy is into its changes while not
directly related to the access
management focus of this breakout on
policies do contain a field related to
the audit logging configuration called
audit can fix when performing changes
intended to grant or revoke access just
be sure not to drop or otherwise modify
this field as you may inadvertently
change your audit logging configuration
right so let's pull what we just went
through in this breakout together into
single example here we have a Python
script intended to add Alice to a
project I am policy granting her the
computer admin role note that we first
begin by retrieving the policy as it
currently exists on the project and I'm
doing so with a requested policy version
of three because our code complies with
all the rules defined in the version
three schema we store that retrieved
policy locally now moving on to the
second part of the Python script we can
begin our local modifications you'll
know that we focus our change
specifically to the binding section of
the retrieve policy simply appending
Alice and her new role grant to the
retrieved policy keeping the changes
focused here safely preserves the e-tag
and audit can fix fields as originally
retrieved next because we know our code
complies with the semantics of the
policy three schema version we can go
ahead and set the policy version to
three while there weren't any conditions
included on the new binding in this
specific example your code will probably
need to accept changes of many different
types some of those may include
conditions as a result any I am clients
you riot can always Express version
three and they're set by on policy calls
so long as the version three semantics
are always safely follow-up finally we
submit the updated policy to Google
Cloud using the set I am policy call
last recap of the breakout make sure to
preserve the e-tag throughout the policy
modification process only touch the
fields you need when modifying and make
sure any programmatic integrations you
develop follow the assumptions baked
into the version three policy schema and
that's all I have for today I'd like to
thank everyone for watching and if you
can't wait to get even more iam info we
have a couple other great sessions
dropping this week I encourage you to
check out covering I am recommender and
policy intelligence both of which can be
an invaluable and helping you achieve
least four bleaching your environments
thanks again have a great day